crimes of the future is the i'm going to
say the most highly anticipated film of
the year as soon as that trailer dropped
your fans freaked out why do you think
it's been eight years since your last
feature filmed
well why do i think
in that time i've written a novel i've
written about three screenplays oh wow
you've been busy yeah and it's a it's
it's strange it takes its own rhythm i
found i mean even in normal times it's
three years between movies you know so
it's really hard to get a an independent
film finance these days and it all
kind of always has been actually so it's
part of part partly that and partly
trying to do some other things yeah what
are you most excited for the fans to see
when it comes to this movie
well uh it's it's my return to genre
filmmaking you know this is uh
it it it is a horror film it is a sci-fi
film maybe it's not a horror film we'll
see how people respond to it but it is
definitely
the genre and i know that a lot of my
the fans of my early films which were
definitely in the genre uh are excited
to see me go back and see i mean it's
been a long time since i did that and uh
i think i've developed become more
interesting maybe we'll see so there's
new stuff in it new stuff well you are
the king of body horse so i personally
cannot wait for this one um i'm so
excited that you're teaming up with vigo
mortensen again i believe this is your
fourth time teaming up with with you uh
what do you love about him well the when
you get vego you don't just get an actor
you really get a full-time
colleague in arms you know you get a a
comrade in arms you get a
a collaborator i mean he is a poet he is
a musician he's a photographer and he's
a director he's actually directed me as
an actor in in his own movie that his
first time directing uh so it's a it's a
full collaboration and i mean we talk
about the script we talk about all the
aspects of the film
uh it's a very unusual kind of
relationship between a director and an
actor yeah well you know kristen stewart
is just the hollywood darling right now
uh everybody wants to work with her what
was it like for you working so close
with her on this i was really impressed
by kristin i mean i of course saw her
from the vampire days and then i've seen
her in a lot of uh the european films
that she's made
but she really blew me away on the set i
have to say i was really
pleasantly surprised because i knew she
was good but i didn't know she was
brilliant but she is brilliant hey
that's a big word i love that yeah okay
and you know as we're wrapping up um i
thought it was so interesting right in
time for the release of this film um
that you are selling an nft
of your past kidney stones you gotta
tell me about this how'd this happen yes
well okay
um
yeah
my daughter caitlyn who's a photographer
she's very much into the nft world and
she kind of encouraged me to first make
a video
i made a video called the death of david
cronenberg and that was my first nft
and i thought well connected with crimes
of the future which discusses
body
uh creativity let's say inner body
creativity i thought well my kidney
stones are my body the inside of my body
trying to express something to the
outside of my body so why not sell them
as a work of art
because if you see a photo of them and i
did collect them i must confess as you
might expect i love it yeah my doctor
wanted to uh have them examined and
broken down so we could say maybe you
need to change your diet and so i said
no these are so beautiful i wouldn't
have you destroy them just to do a
chemical analysis
so yeah if you want to buy my kidney
stones they're available listen i
wouldn't expect anything less from david
cronenberg what a pleasure getting to
talk to you congrats on the film thank
you
you